the allied airlift has unfolded with
remarkable speed western weapons are
offloaded at airfields in poland and
romania driven across the border
and delivered into the hands of the
ukrainian army and its newest fighters
russia has come into my home says this
teacher turned soldier i cannot stay at
home when our country is in danger
there's extreme urgency to the mission
as russian forces continue their advance
there's concern they could choke off the
supply of military support
in the hands of the ukrainian army
american anti-tank missiles have proven
devastatingly effective allegedly
destroying hundreds of russian tanks
western anti-aircraft missiles could be
used to down russian aircraft body armor
helmets and rifles are arriving too all
courtesy of nato allies this is going to
be a long game
for the western unity and that
must must stay
in place as russia gains more ground
nato members have only increased the
frantic pace of shipments even working
on a deal to supply polish fighter jets
to the ukrainian air force there are a
number of challenging practical
questions including how the planes would
actually be transferred from poland to
ukraine and as the weapons move in
they're joined by a growing number of
volunteer fighters from around the world
basically we're here because of the war
crimes that are being committed
ukrainian officials claim 20 000
volunteers from 52 nations have now
signed up to repel the russians but
external support is not limited to
ukraine and its allies the pentagon
believes russia is now trying to recruit
foreign fighters from syria men who are
experienced in the type of devastating
urban combat that russia is now
inflicting on ukraine
jackson prosko global news washington